faire des économies sur sa facture
d'électricité ces ingénieurs et
chercheurs ont peut-être trouvé la
solution
Fabien berger et Jérôme Barbou ont
imaginé la flexbox un boîtier connecté
permettant de stocker et de restituer de
l'électricité et donc d'optimiser sa
consommation une idée qui les a amenés à
collaborer avec Jean-charles buntel
enseignant chercheur à l'université de
Tours où est développé une technologie
essentielle à leur projet un
convertisseur réversible dedans on va
trouver une batterie et un interface qui
va se connecter qui va permettre de
connecter la batterie au réseau
électrique et cette interface va gérer
l'énergie dans les deux sens donc le
même montage va pouvoir recharger la
batterie ou l'inverse récupérer
l'énergie de la batterie pour l'envoyer
sur le réseau une cuisine qui se met en
route un chauffage qui se met en route
on va d'abord puiser dans la batterie
avant de prendre ce réseau électrique
connecté à Internet et au compteur Linky
du foyer la box recevra des informations
extérieures en temps réel sur l'état du
réseau électrique l'état du marché ou
encore l'intensité carbone de
l'électricité produite elle pourra ainsi
adapter son comportement sur le principe
des heures creuses et des heures pleines
pour permettre au foyer de stocker et
consommer de l'électricité moins chère
et plus verte on va agréger toute cette
information la mettre en relation avec
la consommation des clients de La Flèche
box et on va pouvoir piloter en charge
et en décharge pour déplacer ces
consommations ça veut dire charger la
box à un moment où l'énergie est pas
chère n'est pas carbonée pour pouvoir la
décharger à un moment où cette énergie
chère à carbonée donc les pics de
consommation comme on peut les voir le
soir vers 20h ou le matin vers 9h cette
technologie existe déjà mais pas dans un
format aussi compact car la box qu'il
suffira de brancher sur une prise
secteur ordinaire ne dépassera pas une
capacité de stockage d'un kilowatt-heure
et une puissance d'un kilowatt pour
rester silencieuse et faciliter son
utilisation on doit pouvoir la
transporter soi-même on doit pouvoir la
déplacer quand on fait le ménage par
exemple ou quand on déménage et c'est
bête mais une batterie aujourd'hui plus
il y a de capacités plus aller lourde à
transporter et 1 kilowattheure c'est
aujourd'hui la limite pour que ce soit
transportable par une personne et si on
a besoin de plus de capacité et bien on
peut avoir plusieurs box chez soi la
flexbox n'est encore qu'un prototype
mais fractale énergie espère commencer
la certification et l'industrialisation
du produit des 2023 pour le
commercialiser à la fin de l'année